[Music]
hey you guys remember that location
scouting video that came out in this
channel like two or three months ago
that was right when we were shooting
this video they tweeted it out so you
guys saw pictures and you were super
pumped and then we didn't put it out
right away and we did park ride Blood
Dragon instead and we didn't put out
after that we did split her cell instead
and you guys are like what the heck
where's the Zelda video yeah it's like
hey guess what now it's on the internet
so you guys sit back and enjoy it's
behind the scenes we talked about all
these magical tricks that we did to make
it seem like Clinton was actually late
space eartips
like elf space here's like the tips I
got some your tips for you have spirit
gum lag sure packs gone the guns come
out Dan you made this right yeah I made
that that makes all this stuff you made
that I made the knife on my hip
I made that axe I made the scram attacks
on his hip I made that pact Sonny that
axe secondly things bracers they made
those bracers I made this cloak I made
this shirt I made those pants I mean
these pants made this jacket I did not
make these gloves with this chimdale God
made this she's really pretty
yeah and he made me look how much of a
dark elf you'll come on ready do the
dark at my little walk here and then we
set up get a first shot of the day the
Klansmen in the fair to probably do it
mama but I'm a little tired
that's fine and get some air and some of
my whiskey all you scarlet owners out
there you ever shooting in the
wilderness these trees all that business
probably gonna want to be a higher
compression rate say five to one
instead of like you know ten to one
fourteen one because all those little
leaves and details did just get lost in
the compression get an epic shot of
these guys is hiking around the mountain
over here got us some light got some
trees Niko can you hear me cool are we
done with the shot cool
yeah we can we get back to the shade so
like any good piece we have a bunch of
matte paintings in this video but
they're not just any matte paintings
they're matte paintings in force and
what makes that difficult is when you're
trying to isolate trees and put stuff
behind it it gets really hard really
fast you're dealing with very very high
detail objects and you can't go there
and cut out every single leaf and try
and make it look right the opening shot
doesn't even have the sky in the
background we shot that in a canyon so
what I had to do I took reference images
in that same location but of other trees
that were actually set against the sky
once I get to that point all I have to
do is just drop in my elements put some
clouds with hyrule castle in the
background maybe a little bit of fog for
good measure and it looks it looks real
I think all the best angles are kind of
from this side seeing the path curving
and the back it's all backlit and nice
well the lighting doesn't look good over
here so I just that's that's all I'm
thinking I'm not thinking composition a
little bit a little bit I just dropped a
big-ass piece of jewelry came out of
here now I got it
blue failed and then he goes to incur
the shield then we cut through a direct
insert over the top shield reveal no no
all in one shot I think we should get to
an interview
because it makes it a point okay yeah I
guess that's true so as you guys may or
may not know we've actually been pretty
into archery for this past year and for
this video we actually shot a lot of the
arrows practically when you have shots
the arrow fly across the screen or
somebody just shooting a bow we're
usually doing it for real but there's a
couple cases where it's too dangerous to
actually shoot a bow and arrow mainly
because we're actually shooting it at
another person so for half the shots
where arrows are fake we actually just
used a picture of an arrow taken on set
with the same exact lighting condition
in the same exact spot cut it out and
then animated it that's how I did the
arrows hitting the path or the arrow
pinning dark links cloak or just simply
an arrow picture with the anchor point
at the end of the arrow and it made it
to come in and then wobble pretty simple
pretty straightforward looks pretty
realistic throw in a little bit of
action essentials and the tip of the
arrow for some dirt flying up and you're
good to go street kill these fools snap
the necks and cashing checks it's really
great I can't wait so we're gonna be
putting these contacts and Clint sighs
Clint doesn't wear contacts and his eyes
are very finicky so it's gonna be rough
alright just do not stop stop keep
looking over there keep looking wait
stop moving your eyeball see the thing
is you can't move your eyeball ready
boom
okay blink blink blink so this piece not
only do we need arrows to hit the ground
and go flying all over the place we also
needed them to shatter there's a shot
where arrows hit darkling shield and
cheddar and there's a shot word Darkly
cuts the air out of the air and it
breaks and for those we actually needed
a 3d model of the arrow so he had one
from assassin's creed that we took into
3ds max I mean it's ray fire to fracture
it and then run the physics simulation
of it hitting something and breaking all
over the place
physics simulations act just like the
real world in that they're unpredictable
and they kind of just do stuff and they
you know movement looks real but you're
not necessarily getting that style that
personality and your animations that you
want so after running a physics
simulation I would then go in and tweak
some pieces and cause them to spin or
move in a way that made the shot a
little more exciting
action oh god stifled my grief unless my
plan while signaling the left and right
wings in the slope I'm Dan Thompson and
I'm Robert ancona and this is lifestyles
of the un-- wealthy and horribly awesome
I am the Renaissance Harry come from you
could say we frequent the Renaissance
Fair as a matter of fact we weapons
demonstrations and live Valerie
enactments and teaching people the
history of their ways it's swordpoint or
many other thing I can point at them at
any time I've been working the fair for
coming up on 18 years
oh my explain you guys his armor in your
and your kits and everything about him
barbarian kids are so we're wearing
Viking close I can clothing these were
made by me in my tiny little garage shop
with love and pain and blood most of
mine this you're all hand forged they're
all hand fabricated and they are all
battle ready and completely capable of
delivering the kinds of action that you
could expect from a real weapon because
they are yeah look at that they're like
brothers finding my arms services and
other things that are more about me at a
place called epoch arms so there's not a
lot of magical effect shots in this
piece but there's a couple
types however if you break them down
they're all almost the same they all
involve the same three elements which is
basically a lens flare just a big bright
point of energy you have your particle
effects usually I use particular to have
some custom particles that kind of react
with the environment just depending on
what spell it is I have some sort of
stock footage element that I integrate
with each piece to give it a slightly
different tone or feel for example when
he shoots the magical warning flare into
the sky start with a lens flare start
out with a little particular you know
when it explodes and the custom stock
element I'm using in this shot is a
reversed ink droplet just to kind of
simulate some sort of plasma or ether
sucking into his staff before he shoots
it off for the fairy shot even though it
looks different it's the same three
elements we have the lens flare right in
the center we have a little bit of
particular kind of drifting off it
sparkling in the air making a trail and
then a little pair of butterfly wings
I have animated to flap back and forth
basically combine all those and you get
the same cool result using these same
three elements what's up guys it's Dark
Link here
I'm with link right now chillin on a
rock on top of like a little waterfall
as you can see behind me point was over
there so I'm just gonna collect your xp
for you you're already like an
adventuring gear alright well hi We're
Mars rising films that's John that's Tom
and that's Steve cemani could call this
up we did nightmare with them and we
worked on the fus-ro-dah video and like
minecraft and stuff and they were like
hey we want to do this Legend of Zelda
thing what do you guys say we said yeah
so we made the costumes and all the
leathers the armor and brought out dan
and Robbie and chief they came and
they're in our GI Joe video which you
could probably check out right here
find this at youtube.com slash Mars
rising films yeah we got new stuff and
wanted to use it that's why we have all
this and it's kind of cold out here now
there's a way we like to approach sword
fights in our videos and that is to have
a real metal sword for all the close-up
shots or the hero shots and get large
swords for all the actual fights cuz the
large swords let us go all out let's go
fast be brutal without hurting each
other and their style back to the Master
Sword but then we did a little bit of
extra painting to make them extra
realistic where I was trying to do a
fight scene with these it's bad idea
I'm just gonna break in metal flying
into everybody's eyes and we're all
gonna die hey what's up my name is
Gerren Simpson I'm here on the set for
link shadow I'm playing the role of link
here the light one versus my dark
nemesis Dark Link right now we're just
kind of going through the fight choreo
for our little bout here we both kind of
kill each other yeah we're here in the
middle of Park in the middle of nowhere
it's pretty cool there's no people is no
nothing so just gonna get it done yeah
are you just tying it to there yeah
[Applause]
which is too bad
I've been great to do it all but I know
and it gives us time to just really make
sweet shots what we did get was really
good so I'm really not that disappointed
like I'm actually really happy with what
happened like all this all the footage
looked great
the name is cool we shot the cool shots
every single shot we shot today was pure
wholesome goodness the day of epic shots
that's well he'll be forever known as
the day of of epic shots
it's the Space Station flying behind me
at a couple thousand miles an hour or
something probably like that estimated
17,000 I knew was a couple thousand
you